hi Mariah hello welcome back well thanks
your life is making steady progress in a
better direction right yes absolutely
big difference yeah yeah
very few people make it out of that
lifestyle
the
you're doing a great job of it tell me
what's going on
well
um currently I don't work fig anymore I
don't do any more drugs
um
I had a little one another one
um the first one the first video I had
with you um I was pregnant with my
daughter
Unfortunately they did take her
I'm in the process of getting her back
it's a difficult very difficult process
like but I'm trying the best I can
to the best of my ability
like with the support I do have you know
like At first with my daughter I didn't
have no support you know with this
little man right here I have a lot of
support who is this this is my son
Infinity
how old he's eight days now eight days
yeah wow
foreign
yeah that's nice it's nice to have help
yes it is
because I was a mother already with my
daughter
and
I wasn't able to raise her though you
know so now she's bigger than him but
I do visit her all the time like I
literally just came from a visit with
her right now
she met him for the first time
it's a little hard you know walking away
from her but knowing that I got one so
far
and I'm on the right path like
um
it's a lot more relieving stress living
in like I know I can get my daughter
back
where's your daughter now my daughter's
in foster care right now
and drugs are tell me the story with
your drug situation yeah I was on drugs
with my daughter well
it was more so like
I was on drugs don't get me wrong but I
stopped
um at the end of it but I didn't stop in
the right amount of time
um when I found out I was pregnant with
him
I stopped everything I just couldn't
have another child taking for me
you had how many children how many kids
have you had two just two whatever
and how are you supporting yourself now
um honestly
I'm just taking a day at a time like
whatever comes like and I've been
getting blessed quite a few times
whether it was like
well I wouldn't say blessed because the
only money I've been receiving was like
little payments from my like my um
injury I'm going through but it's been
keeping me how do you say it
it's been keeping me able to take care
of myself in this little one so far so
you have housing now I don't I'm still
in the process of trying to get housing
and that's the most difficult part
especially leaving the hospital with a
newborn like you know even though I left
the hospital with a newborn newborn that
does not make it easier for me to get
housing like
it does not
it's just as hard as it is for everybody
else to get housing like
it's just another life that I have to
you know to add to a case and
then they try to split you away like
they try to put they try to give a place
where they could place the dad with the
baby but mom has to wander around like
that don't that don't make sense to me
oh Dina how old are you 25 now 25 now
[Music]
do you have no family
no I don't
other than this beautiful family that I
just created of my own me my baby father
this little guy and
my daughter she'll be back soon
that would be great that would be great
where do you see yourself going for the
next like five years
should be with my family you stay in L.A
you're gonna stay in L.A I don't want to
stay away it's expensive here it's not
even being an expensive part I could
care less but like you know like
treat yourself don't treat yourself you
know but
it's more so of my I need to stay
focused on my family and things so with
that being said it's like
I gotta get away from all this it's like
you know how when they tell you
to you can't change when you're in the
same environment doing the same thing
like you know like around the same
people oh maybe I could do this
different
you're doing the same thing in the same
environment with the same people it's
not gonna go too much different so I
just rather like
move my remove myself from what I know
is like
um
my mess up Zone which is LA
yeah Figueroa Street I don't know if
anyone's really getting ahead of the
game down there man the last time I
worked big I almost got killed I'm good
looking back at that life
looking back at that life that you were
leading before and I got a daughter now
too and I'll be down if I ever see my
daughter out there I can't do it
I'm not going to say I treat her any
different but it'll hurt me
so
an example for your kids exactly
when I was able to leave the hospital
with this one though
I knew I was going to be able to change
something you learn from your mistakes
maybe yeah I guess you could say that
yeah
it's my little lifesaver
don't get me wrong it's hard it's hard
whether it's like
emotional you know like
it's stressful
like they'll run around the people give
you for this disability and stuff you
know like it's very very very very
stressful
and it's been a couple moments where
I'm like man
am I gonna get through this
like I question myself but I had to stop
doing it
like and I just gotta tell myself I'm
gonna get through it and just figure out
how I'm gonna get through it I've been
getting through it this far with the
negative so
gotta be able to do something positive
what did you learn from your ups and
downs over the last few years
my main thing is it's not myself no more
I gotta like do this for my kids you
know you know
and although like of course you know
everything is easier said than done you
know it's the part of trying to make it
to get it done you know how full like
how
how um
how you say it like
I feel like they're worth it so I'm
gonna do it
like you know
kids become your priority
exactly
it's hard don't get me wrong it's hard
but I'd rather be happy with my family
rather than you know high in the streets
just going and going and going not
knowing what's going on just going and
going and going now nowhere to go next
streets are cold
I came home from the hospital
with him and
I was just like man where the [__] could
I go where do I go I didn't have nowhere
to go
I didn't have nowhere to go with my baby
but I knew I wasn't gonna lie I wasn't
gonna let them take him
like I I did something I made a
sacrifice to my life I'm not saying it
was
I'm not saying I wouldn't have did it or
anything but I made a sacrifice to want
to change my life everybody don't make
those choices you know some it's a lot
of people with kids and that like
just don't care
but I was a foster kid I don't know my
parents I don't know my parents at all
and I want to make a difference
it's great
maybe you'll be
you'll be the one who changes the
direction of your
your kids lives because
not having a parent
yeah it's just I have so many questions
right now as an adult
if I was severed like meet my mom or dad
or whatever you know
I'm not mad at them but I just got a lot
of questions you know
and
I feel like that's kind of like the
missing pieces of my like puzzle which I
would say is my life that I'm missing
that I I'm trying I've been so focused
on like trying to get I've been trying
to find my parents I don't know
I kind of like
it bugs me sometimes especially now that
I have kids now I refuse though I refuse
I can't do it then like that I can't
walk away and just leave them
well all these questions are stuff
I don't do that
it's like I said I want to get my my
first my daughter back like it was so
hard to go over there I have to walk
away from her
but just having him that just makes me
know I'm a step closer though
maybe you can be the parent to your son
and daughter that your mom was not to
you to me correct
all right all right good luck with
everything thank you happy for you thank
you
stay on track
proud of you
thank you